we are told that quadrilateral abcd is
dilated about point p so this is our
quadrilateral that's going to be dilated
around point p and then they ask us some
questions are the coordinates of the
vertices preserved our corresponding
line segments on the same line
are angle measures preserved our side
lengths perimeter and area preserved so
pause this video and see if you can
answer it
so now let's work through it together so
one thing you might be thinking is
they're just saying it's dilated they
didn't say what the scale factor is we
know it's dilated about point p but
what's the scale factor
well since they didn't tell us i guess
these questions would apply to any scale
factor but to help us visualize this
let's just apply a scale factor here
let's just say that our scale factor
scale factor so it fits on this page is
equal to one-half
so what would result here well right now
point a is 1 two three four five six
seven eight away from point b
so its image if we do a scale factor of
one half would be four away one two
three four so
right over there point a prime could be
right over there it would be along the
same line it would just be half as far
point d is right now one two three four
five six away so d prime would be
three away half as far away
and so this would be the segment a prime
d prime which corresponds to the segment
ad
now let's see point b
if we have a scale factor of one half it
is
one two three four five six below a but
if we have a scale factor of one half
it's going to be 3 below a
so this would be our
b prime
and so you could also see that if you
connect a line going from point p to b
that b prime is also on that line is
just half as far scale factor of one
half
now point c there's a couple of ways we
could think about it to go from point p
to point c
we have to go four down and to the left
so if you apply a scale factor of one
half you go
2 down and 1 to the left so this would
be c prime right over here and so
a prime b prime c prime
d prime
the image of quadrilateral abcd after
the dilation around point b and i picked
an arbitrary scale factor here that i
felt that i could draw you see it right
over here and the reason why i did that
is it makes it a little bit easier to
answer this question are the coordinates
of the vertices preserved
well every
vertex all the vertices are different
coordinates here so we would say no none
of those are preserved
are the and the whole idea here is to to
appreciate what gets preserved or
doesn't get preserved under dilations
are corresponding line segments on the
same line
well let's see no they're all parallel
to each other so a b is parallel to a
prime b prime a d is parallel to a prime
d prime and so on and so forth but
they're not all none of them are on the
same line so i would say no
and then we say our angle measures
preserved so this is something that
dilations do preserve so this angle is
still the same as that angle this was a
right angle before it's still a right
angle this angle is still
equal to that angle or the measure of
those angles
likewise the measure of that angle is
still equal to the measure of that angle
so angle measures are preserved and
that's a general thing that you could
take away about dilations
are side lengths perimeter and area
preserved
well dilations are a non-rigid
transformation which tells you that side
lengths are not preserved the distance
between corresponding points are not
preserved and you could see it very
clearly here and if side lengths aren't
preserved then perimeter is definitely
not preserved and then area would not be
preserved so this would be no for all of
these under a dilation if we were
talking about a rigid transformation
like a translation or a rotation then
these three would be preserved let's do
another example
so we're told triangle abc is dilated
about point c once again they don't tell
us what the scale factor and then they
ask us the same four questions so like
before pause this video see if you can
figure it out on your own
now let's work through it together and
i'm just going to apply a scale factor
in fact you know might as well do a
scale factor of one-half
so scale factor i'll just do sf for
short let's say it's equal to one-half
and i'm just picking one so that we can
visualize what its image would look like
after the dilation
so let's see right now remember we're
this is interesting because we're
dilating around a point that happens to
be one of the vertices of the triangle
so let's see point a to go from c to a
we go
3 to the left and we go 2 4 6 up
6 up
just like that
so
two to the left and then six up so if
you have a scale factor of one half or
sorry not two to the left three to the
left
three to the left and six up and so if
you have a scale factor of one half
instead you're gonna go one and a half
to the left and then three up and so
you're going to end up right over there
now this is a prime and so notice this
is actually sitting on the segment ac
and that happens to be the case because
once again our center of dilation is one
of the vertices of our actual triangle
now let's look up think about b where b
prime would be to go from c to b we go 2
to the right
and then we go 4 up plus 4.
so if we are talking about a scale
factor of one-half we'll go one-half as
far to the right and one-half as far up
so one to the right and two up so this
would be where b-prime is and so there
we have
the image
and of course c would map to c prime
because it's it's actually the point
that we are dilating about
so this would be our image right over
here a prime b prime and c prime
so are the coordinates of the vertices
preserved well only
only c is preserved the other ones are
not preserved and the only reason why c
was preserved is because that is the
point we are dilating about i have this
third time i said in my apologies
our corresponding line segments on the
same line
well
a prime
c prime
same
on same line i guess you could say
on
same
line
as
ac
and similarly
c prime b prime or i could say b prime c
prime
same
i'm just going to use a little shorthand
and once again that is because we are
dilating about a point that is one of
the vertices the other segment a prime b
prime is not
not
a prime
b prime it's not on the same line it is
parallel this is parallel to that but it
is not on the same line
are angle measures preserved well we
don't even have to look at this this is
going to be a yes this is one of the
things about dilation angle measures are
preserved that angle is equal to that
angle the measure of this angle is
congruent to that angle or this angle is
congruent to that angle and of course
this is the same angle in both cases our
side lengths perimeters and area
preserved once again no when we're doing
a dilation side lengths and the side
legs aren't preserved perimeter is not
going to be preserved and area is not
going to be preserved and we're done